- Oy, mate.
This you?
- I believe it is.
- Wicked.
You coaching football.
You are a legend for
doing something so stupid.
I mean, it's mental.
They're gonna murder you.
- This is a bit of news from
the other side of the Atlantic.
AFC Richmond announced
the hiring of their new manager
American football coach Ted Lasso.
- You are an American who is now
in charge of a football club
despite possessing very little
knowledge of the game.
-Ooh!
I know that AFC Richmond
is gonna give you
everything they got, win or lose.
- Or tie.
- Right! Y'all do ties here.
- You don't know what you're doing!
You don't know what you're doing!
- Did you see that?
He must be from England, yeah?
- Wales.
- Is that another country?
- Yes and no.
- How many countries are in this country?
- Four.
- Like it or not, Richmond
are changing the way we do things,
and from now on,
that way is the Lasso way.
(car horn honks)
- Hey, look! This car's got
an invisible steering wheel!
(car horn honks)
- What you're doing is irresponsible.
This club actually means
something to this town.
- You don't think I see that
every day out there on the streets?
- Are you kidding me?
I think that's what it's all about,
embracing change.
- Same team!
- Being brave.
- Your decision to bench Jamie
was a masterstroke.
- I don't think we're allowed to
talk like that at work anymore.
♪ You got no fear of the underdog ♪
- For me, success is not about
the wins and losses.
It's about helping these young fellas
be the best versions of themselves
on and off the field.
- (slurps) I always figured that tea
was just gonna taste like hot brown water.
And you know what? I was right.
Yeah, it's horrible. No, thank you.
- Welcome to England.